[Music]
that's all i know so far but i'm gonna
keep practicing
it's good you know i had never been out
of the country
before now huh got to see how jamaicans
live
it is great you know they just relax
they party all the time
it's kind of an impoverished country
yeah gosh
great you know what pam make a note
i want us all to start having pina
coladas
every day at three you can't today we're
doing inventory
inventories at the end of december we
couldn't do it without you so we
postponed
i specifically went on vacation so i
would miss it inventory is boring
in the islands they don't make you do
stuff like take inventory
why do you think so many businesses move
to the caymans tonight
we are going to have an inventory luau i
want to bring back
a little slice of paradise to the dunder
mifflin warehouse
inventory so party planning committee
get on it
by the end of the day that's impossible
the jamaicans don't have a word for
impossible yep it's english it's
impossible
michael there's no way we can do it in
time how hard is a luau
all you need are some grass skirts
pineapple poi
tiki torches suckling pig some fire
dancers
that's all you need here is our official
retreat schedule it divides our time
evenly between work and play come on
everybody let's hustle
let's get to the brainstorming great
attitude ron
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible so i can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me it's like yoga
except i still get to kill something
all right i call this wonderful spot
you didn't bring a tent well i don't
really go camping ever
jerry so i'm not gonna spend 150 on a
tent just gonna sleep on the floor
it's called the ground when it's outside
pam
i have a very important job for you
today i thought we were just having fun
at the beach
we are we are all participating in
mandatory
fun activities fun tivities
and there is a special secret prize for
the winner
yes funtivities all right find a cozy
spot
everybody settle in
okay everybody up
circle around let us play some games
this is so great
yeah seagulls check the ocean
check a gang of oldies and short shorts
check check
check we are definitely on a cruise
welcome aboard
say i love carousel cruises
international ltd
i love carousel cruises internationally
i don't want to say that
all right so the sail away party
is in an hour and until then i have a
schedule to take in live music at the
all ages piano lounge
okay okay or we could just head straight
to the room i brought a plastic tarp so
we can eat shrimp in bed
but the all ages piano lounge has
bottomless margaritas
they also have a drink with a potato
skin in it oh to the all ages piano
lounge
murderer
welcome aboard ladies and gentlemen but
especially ladies
i know that voice get ready it's time
for some smush songs
ah duck judy the pontiac bandit
he's here all my life i have avoided
europe
and its multitudes of terribleness but
it turns out much to my surprise
there is actually one place in europe
that is worth seeing
[Music]
these tiny islands off the coast of
scotland
where god's chosen elixirs are distilled
barreled and prepared for consumption
this is worth the trip
dear ron you have now reached the
cliffsides overlooking the islands
as you sit here and gaze upon the waters
please read out loud the poem by the
great scotsman robert burns
love leslie
a worm i love yon lilac fair
with purple blossoms to the spring and i
a bird
to shelter there when wearied on my
little wing
how i would mourn when it was torn
by autumn wild and winter rude
but i would sing on wanton wing
when youthful may it's bloom renewed
[Music]
i don't know what she thought i'd get
out of that
[Music]
this jet is insane there's a private
chef that'll make anything you ask for
no matter how expensive i just ordered
lobster ashantay oh damn what's that i
don't know i just said the fanciest
words i could think of oh
i'm gonna get the vo prime minister hmm
that sounds good
hey you want to try out the smush shush
what you have one with you i'll take it
everywhere baby
yeah there it is yeah so it's noise
canceling
it's so heavy it's crushing my bones
yeah that was the shark's problem with
it too i can't breathe get off me
get off me you sound exactly like
barbara right now
disappointed in you jake pilot says
we're starting our descent then let's
get changed boys
changed but these are my coolest clothes
i got them from a targeted instagram ad
after looking at photos of cam newton
outfit is beautiful but it doesn't
really say
miami what does say miami
are you sure this is culturally okay for
me we're gonna find out all right
[Music]
i can't believe this place is real
i mean i've heard about his beef farm
for years but i know it's the beets
motel
the beets motel that is wow
thank you abortion hotel
oh the embassy beats radish in
how are you doing i don't know
oh my gosh
um
i'd say one in six what
i thought you asked me what our chances
were being murdered here tonight
you know i just realized this is pam's
and my first night away together
i used to play it over my head and it
was just a little bit different
maybe a nice hotel or a romantic dinner
wine um but wine that wasn't made out of
beets
didn't think dwight would be involved at
all and uh
i always imagined less manure you need
to spread it i mean some manure
just it's gonna work less this is beet
food
moe's what are you doing nomos put the
put the manure down
put it down do not throw it do not ow
and harry saw the white hand
raise its wand and felt voldemort's
surge of vicious anger
saw the frail old man on the floor
writhe in agony
harry it was over as quickly as it had
come
harry stood shaking in the darkness
clutching the gate into the garden his
heart racing
dwight how's the hotel business stupid
have you checked tripadvisor recently no
maybe you should maybe you should
whatever
we wrote a good review under comments we
wrote
the natural aroma of the beats drifts
into the bedrooms and makes you dream of
simpler times
the dawn goose walk will tug at your
heartstrings
table making never seemed so possible
you will never
want to leave your room the architecture
reminds one of a quaint tuscan beet farm
i'm glad you enjoyed your stay he's
leaving our plan worked we saved our own
honeymoon and fun bonus we cheered up
holt yes
okay it's time to celebrate you know
what that means this bee needs a c
in her a oh my god this babe needs a
coconut in her arms oh
i thought you were saying this music oh
my god yeah that was my reaction all
right i'll go get us a couple of
coconuts
healing hot
you